hello screen junkies welcome to the long
and somewhat overdue commentary for the
honest trailer for boss baby yeah
I'm Spence J Gilbert this is Stan Merle
hi and new year happy new year it's good
to be back and it's good to be back dan
where do babies come from well accordin
is this movie that come from a factory
in the sky and they may or may not
actually be born and they come in a taxi
I don't know I thought that this movie
would clear it up for me and I've
questioned dances that was my
recollection of it so full disclosure
first of all we're gonna watch the
honest trailer for boss baby we're gonna
give you our detailed thoughts about it
and maybe break down some behind the
scenes stuff and maybe some deleted
scenes do we have any JT we do stick
around for those but full disclosure I
wrote this maybe like two weeks before
we even went on break and remember
nearly nothing about it except that it
was strange this was the last movie the
last one that we produced before the
holiday break oh he wrote next weeks
which we'll talk about at the end of
this this is a fan but by the way our
fan poll this is the first movie thanks
fan oh thanks fans this is the year and
you go with boss baby prospect you know
do you have movies money this movie made
worldwide no half a billion dollars oh
so there's a lot of people out there
that like this movie didn't even come
out in China still made half a billion
dollars why I don't know people love
this movie it's like minions I think
kids just like things that go like this
shape roughly yeah and make noises
didn't make noise yeah that's that's the
key
yeah I I'm trying to remember to write
this movie broke my head a little bit
right cuz this film doesn't need to be
as much as extra as it is because it has
the premise itself is makes sense it's
like oh it's a metaphor for what a new
baby comes home and the only child feels
like now the other babies the boss and
they don't get love and attention but
they're like first of all we're taking
that literally literally there's a
limited zero sum amount of love in the
world that this baby is stolen from you
yes and that baby is also engaged in
corporate espionage and warfare against
the company that makes puppies which is
started by a guy who used to be a boss
baby lactose-intolerant couldn't drink
the milk that kept him a baby
all going on in his mind's eye yeah and
then but then this is at least they
established rules and then they break
them yeah it's really weird and bizarre
and it's very difficult to follow in a
weird way like not in a plot level but
just on an existential level yeah yeah
this is a weird weird ask because even
because the whole film like takes a long
time to explain by also dodging where
babies come from I never see the point
of conception where these babies are
truly made they begin already on the
conveyor on a conveyor belt and the
women are pregnant where's baby
processing where's baby assembly I don't
know we will never know well maybe -
that's baby - the whole baby expanded
universe yeah it's a bleak crazy movie
you BBE check that out and yeah beyond
that I don't know it's it's the latest
in this long line of like um you know
Patrick Stewart is the poop and well
Kevin Spacey did enough to ruin his name
but as the cat in nine lives so what if
thought 9 lives would be the second
worst thing you ever did by a mile of
the year yeah yeah this is Alec Baldwin
he's kind of I guess he's is it a career
resurgence for him I guess so this is
very this is a good character for him it
is good and he fits it in the same way
that Liam Neeson now only does a killer
on and on a transportation mode things
he it's taken on a plane now it's taken
on a train Alec Baldwin is now you know
a fast-talking materialistic boss yeah
that's his move now it's this thing
that's he perfected it in Glengarry Glen
Ross which is a reference at the end of
this video
mm-hmm I'm 30 rock 30 rock did the White
House
Trump and now this yep there you go got
in somewhere yeah but let's begin the
honest trailer for the boss maybe boss
baby your votes number five or small
voted for the 2017 news vote wanted us
to do an honest trailer for
here's your mom or anything ever I meant
in the broader sense president how to
train your dragon made you feel now
DreamWorks newest franchise will make
you question the very fabric of reality
boss baby no seriously it's a weird one
meet boss baby his actual given name who
also happens to be a boss a baby and a
boss a baby version of alec baldwin is
the same restroom babies for closers
coffee's for closers only do you need
samuel squeaky you called for ice cream
sure here's two scoops but if you think
that's all there is to this kids flick
hold on to your powdered buds for a
sharp left turned into madness where the
companies who manufacture babies and
puppies compete for the limit laws go
back to the conveyor belt if you can't
change the baby convey this is where
babies come from this is the factory no
handrails it's in the sky yeah it's in
the sky so is there some kind of a
religious method that the movie storks
have a monopoly on the stork plotline
maybe that's a good question they're
made in some corporate issues there I
would love if they pan down and there
was just a uncountable pile of dead
babies it's very 2011 you don't get to
do that unless you're an acclaimed
independent director huh
I'm thinking about next week sorry Oh
[Laughter]
actually a weird when you think about it
and it'll make sense that people see it
there is a weird kind of connection
between this boss baby Jesus Christ this
is this starts out weird with this baby
thing and there's like a willy wonka
type good egg bad egg judging device
that's a look into management versus
down a slide into yeah does the slide go
into the mother's womb it directly but
then they come in a taxi so but maybe
the only I don't anyway I've got
inspired we're getting ahead of our
meeting at our society babies and
puppies compete for the limited amount
of love in the world this is war
puppies are winning and babies buzz baby
Quinn that's the scariest part of the
movie is that there is a set amount of
love that is eaten up by any new thing
you love which they never explain away
or say was not the case so really the
only children do have to worry about
their siblings taking love literally
away from yes all children I mean litter
the literal end game of the villain in
this movie is that he invents something
that will make parents stop loving their
children children forever spring and
once all that love is gone you will
never get it back and there's nothing
you this is a this is some twisted I
don't know who this is some twisted
stuff like this is so dark and so like
just you scratch the surface underneath
it and it's like this could have been a
lars von trier movie but they just
animated it instead they sold it to
DreamWorks or whoever oh my god if you
get like a skarsgård just like staring
into the middle distance and talking
about you know how it doesn't love his
baby anymore that's I thought - my
mother used to love me until we got the
dog
zip puppy the eternal puppy this is
always they're so cute okay let's let's
keep watchin just don't scar scar
doesn't talk like that doesn't matter
okay baby going boys have adult level
intelligence but drink laced milk to
keep their bodies tiny without that
formula I turned into a normal baby
pacifiers that let you ask to project
yourself through physical space I want
you to suck it and a memory wiping baby
task force can make you forget your own
children forget about the baby forget
about the baby so if you think Logan was
the darkest action maybe the key
I've already had two hens and for sure
the craziest you haven't really listened
to anything I just said
as your child ever asked where babies
come from get ready to dodge that
question with 90 minutes of lies that
will take years of therapy to undo I
wasn't born I was hired where babies
start life when the dangerous assembly
line get assigned their sex be a pinball
machines oh that's right it's the sex
yeah so they're not render it was the
sex but what else is decided by a ping
pong and like that it was it was
separating the boys from the girls now
the question is is it assigning them
their their gender or is it just sorting
them by gender oh that's it says
something about this movie right it's
the fourth-most existential question
that the movie has well Dan gender
exists on a spectrum it's physical yes
boss baby - we'll get more into that I
guess so we're we're gonna have more
gender neutral babies I guess yeah this
is so confusing it's so confusing I
think what is it what all those devices
do in the head
there's a baby butt powdering device
there's a diapering device yeah there's
a pacifying as you can see I mentioned
earlier in the conveyor belt they
tackled race yeah so this is a this goes
deep and if you go to the right you're
Lisa Kudrow I love it they got Tobey
Maguire to be the voice in this movie
who I always thought looked like a baby
yeah but he doesn't play a baby he does
not he plays it yeah he does play a
grown-up version of a child player X in
Molly's game plays player acts who are
supposed to be Tobey Maguire that's a
whole different thing that's a whole
different thing
all right weird what a weird dude get a
sign their sex be a pinball machine and
even though it looks like women still
get pregnant the baby shows up in a taxi
but then what happened to them
no this can't be easier to explain than
saying mommy and daddy want to bone
sometimes no wonder kids are so messed
up there's more than just babies along
for the ride like Tim the boy who shows
you how obnoxious only children can be
how would you like to have a baby
brother
no thanks I'm enough whose imagination
was as an only child yeah I still wanted
a brother growing up so yeah I have an
only child and I just like stuff you
actually that makes sense because you
softer than that I think the original
line was how knowing only children are I
did I said I said that's a little that's
a little harsh and that's true my my
wife's an only child and wanted a she
had an imaginary brother so I was
heartbroken at not having one but like
that I wasn't offended by the concept of
having another child in the house you
didn't have like super enabling parents
like this kid did we were like yeah it's
yeah I don't know kids had some thinking
and learning to do and I don't know if
he did any of it whose imagination
borders on clinical insanity colossal
big fat boss baby who's made a puppy so
cute it will literally steal a mother's
love from her kids
this movie is weird and we haven't even
touched on the part where the
seven-year-old gets hammered in Vegas
Elvis impersonator up the diaper that
was once your brain as you question
whether anything on screen is real or
not
because Tim falls asleep at the
beginning so it's all fake but then the
mom is actually pregnant so it's real
but it's all from Tim's point of view so
it's fake but the parents acknowledge
the baby is wearing a suit so it must be
real he's like a little man but the
action is shown to be exaggerated
so it's fake but Tim records the baby
actually talking so that's real but the
parents never hear the tape so it's fake
but the parents do hear the baby talk so
it's real yes the baby's fine well what
bad but at the end grownup Tim says it's
just how he remembers it so it's fake
but his daughter is also a boss baby so
it's real Starlin movie
take it anymore you broke it me so if
you're looking at his head never would
have come up with on their own you can't
be fired from your own family enjoy this
acid trip but if you ever get
overwhelmed sit back and enjoy the
office talk but now I know that memos
are very important things no one shall
suddenly pay for lots and lots of
violence looks like that the pause for a
second actually like this about the
movie this really was like same with
Secret Life of pets we expect these
things to be Pixar Pixar's ruined us for
children's movie every song why isn't
this making me think about my own life
they only you emotionally they
do the physical jeopardy rights early
toys yeah but it's it's changed the way
I walk into a children's animated
feature which isn't fair
yeah you know I shouldn't go in being
like oh I I'm kind of get jokes for
adults and I'm gonna have like themes of
death and redemption stuff like it no
it's a cartoon yeah I remember walking I
think I like the pencils like who's that
me for children children's I'm spoiled
by these other animated movies that are
made for both yeah yeah yeah and it just
remind me I like that part of the kids
the multiple personality disorder
psychosis or whatever it was that they
would switch animation styles during
action sequences was pretty cool and
like there's a lot of like Looney Toon
style violence that was or wasn't
happening yeah was happening did the
baby get thrown through a window or did
it not I think it did yeah he blocked
out the blood either this is such a
confusing set of reality rules and those
babies smart babies that have been
artificially kind of like he was kind of
he was kind of between he's kind of dumb
so is every baby just smarter than
they're letting on
or his only boss babies that way I don't
know that's good they they were drinking
the milk better we should do one of
those serious questions video soon about
vos baby was very serious questions
about boss baby alright let's finish
this up hey stop it
this is literally child abuse story
Alec ball with Tobey Maguire a friend of
Steve Buscemi a UH scary poppins y'all
and the Camino cloning facilities Glenn
baby Glenn boss nicely done Dan thank
you I think this couple tons is
first-class why is it no one can afford
it
that that is more socio-economic
commentary that I expect for my talking
baby Phil's yeah yeah it was kind
undercurrent a fatigue of capital it
keeps you from experiencing love yeah
true your love being dictated by a
corporation you know by corporate
mandate and marketing and since like
again so many confusing layers to this
movie none which really come together
no but there's interesting threads which
is why I would love it if they gave the
sequels to like a Lars von Trier to I
don't know who's doing some like a to a
David Lynch yeah yeah maybe Coen
Brothers like a Barton Fink cash like
baby and then he got John Goodman
obviously would be the voice of a boss
baby man well you guys asked for it you
asked for it we did it for some reason
it wasn't terrible like there was
interesting threads in it and it wasn't
the worst movie of the year it was super
weird yeah yeah it was super weird it's
based on a book I'm curious about
reading the book now yeah um I can't
wait for boss baby - yeah yeah I guess
we should watch some
what Aryans okay let's see story baby
boomer Donald Trump great value Gandalf
a talking thumb wearing glasses nanny
mcphee scary poppins
head where babies come from slides
adorable bosses no wait a wolf of Wall
Street yeah yeah well I forgot
everything about that until just
watching it so yeah there you go there
you go your movie your choice so
congratulations and you guys really kept
it up with next week which we alluded to
make it a weird movies gonna strange
stuff it only gets weirder from here you
know we put this I you know we put
together the list of movies that we you
know could do trailers for because it
was the list of people that people could
vote on was a there were some of us who
took out because it's like there's no
honest trailer to be had there sure this
was one that we put on there out of
sheer morbid curiosity
mmm-hmm that's awful no one would vote
for and it ended up being in the top
five so for me once you know what I'd
rather do this than another Transformers
movie and in that respect you also
failed us yes so way to go guys what do
you but we're not doing it you know
we're not doing another another what I
don't know I was I'd lost it boss maybe
broke my brain i derailed in the middle
of that sentence boss maybe we broke all
of us but we're back were refreshed and
even though we don't really remember
what happened with this one we'll be
back next week with another thrilling
episode of honest trailer commentaries
for an even stranger movie very weird
okay ii hope to see you then
[Music]
you